hello everyone so this is what i might
call a more optional video in the last
couple videos i talked about this
multi-variable chain rule and i gave
some justification and it might have
been considered a little bit hand wavy
by some i was doing a lot of things that
looked kind of like taking a derivative
with respect to t and then multiplying
that by an infinitesimal quantity dt and
thinking of canceling those out and some
people might say ah but this isn't
really a fraction that's a that's a
derivative that's a differential
operator and you're treating it
incorrectly and while that's true the
intuitions underlying a lot of this
actually matches with a formal argument
pretty well so what i want to do here is
just talk about what the formal argument
behind
behind the multivariable chain rule is
and just to remind ourselves of the
setup of where we are
you're thinking of v as a vector-valued
function so this is something that takes
as an input t that lives on a number
line and then v maps this
to some kind of high dimensional space
right
in the simplest case you might just
think of that as a two-dimensional space
maybe it's three-dimensional space
or it could be a hundred dimensional you
don't have to literally be visualizing
it
and then f our function f somehow takes
that 100-dimensional space or
two-dimensional three-dimensional
whatever it is
and then maps it onto the number line so
the overall effect of the composition
function is to just take a real number
to a real number so it's a single
variable function so that's why we're
taking this ordinary derivative rather
than you know a partial derivative or
gradient or anything like that but
because it goes through a
multi-dimensional space and you have
this intermediary multivariable nature
to it that's why you have a gradient and
a vector value derivative so with the
formal argument the first thing you
might do is just write out the formal
definition of a derivative and in this
case
it's a limit
definitions of derivatives are always
going to be some kind of limit as a
variable goes to zero and here you're
loosely thinking about h as being dt and
you could write delta t but it's common
to use h just because that that can be
used for whatever your differential
quantity is so that's on the denominator
because you think of it as dt and the
top is whatever the change to this whole
function is when you nudge that input by
t and what i mean by that is you'll take
f
of v
not of t but of t plus h that kind of
nudged output value and you're wondering
how different that is
from f of v of t your original value
v of t
so this is what happens when you just
apply the formal definition of the
derivative the ordinary derivative
to your composition function
and now
what do you do as you're trying to
reason about what this should equal and
a good place to start actually is to
look back to the intuition that i was
giving for the multivariable chain rule
in the first place you imagine nudging
your input by some dt
some tiny change and i was saying oh so
that causes a change in the intermediary
space
of some kind of
you know you could call it dv a change
in the vector and the way that you're
thinking about that is you take the
vector value derivative and multiply it
by dt
it's the proportionality constant
between the size of your nudge and the
resulting vector and loosely you might
imagine those dts crossing out
as if they were fractions doesn't really
matter and then you say what is this
change this change by a dv cos for f and
by definition
the resulting nudge to the output space
of f
is the directional derivative in the
direction of whatever your vector nudge
is
of the function f so this is the loose
intuition and where does that carry over
to formality you say well in this
intermediary space we had to deal with
the vector value derivative of v so it
might be a good thing to just write down
that definition right write down the
fact
that the definition
for the vector value derivative of v
again it looks almost identical all
these derivative definitions really do
look
look kind of the same because what
you're doing is you're taking the limit
as h goes to zero h we're still thinking
of as being dt
so it kind of sits on the bottom but
here you're just wondering how your
vector changes
and the difference even though you know
we're kind of writing this the same way
and it looks almost identical
notationally what's on the numerator
here this v of t plus h and this v of t
these are vectors so this is kind of a
vector minus a vector so when you take
the limit you're getting a limiting
vector something in your high
dimensional space it's not just a number
and now another way to write this one
that's um more helpful more conducive to
manipulation is to say not that it
equals the limit of this value and i'm
going to go ahead and just kind of copy
this value here
kind of down here
and say
the value of our derivative actually
equals this subject to some kind of
error which i'll just write as e of h
like an error function of h
and what you should be thinking is that
that error function goes to zero as h
goes to zero this is just writing things
so that we're able to manipulate it a
little bit more easily so i'll give
ourselves some room here
and what you can do with this is
multiply all sides by h
so this is our vector value derivative
just rewriting it
multiplied by h and you're thinking of
this h is a dt so maybe in the back of
your mind you're kind of thinking of
canceling this dt with the h and what it
equals is this top this numerator here
which was
v of t plus h
minus v of t
and the back of your mind you might be
thinking this whole thing represents
you know dv
a change in v so the idea of canceling
out that dt with the h really does kind
of come through here but the difference
between the more hand-waving argument
before of canceling those out and what
we're doing here is now we're accounting
for
that error function that in this case
it's now multiplied by h because
everything was multiplied by h error
function
and there's actually another way that
i'm going to write this
there's a
very useful convention in analysis where
i'll take something like this and
instead i'll write it as little o
of h and this isn't literally a function
it's just a in to say whatever this is
whatever function that represents it
satisfies the property that when we take
that function and divide it by h
that will go to zero as h goes to zero
right which is true here because you
imagine taking this and dividing by h
and that would be this h cancels out and
you just have your error function is
going to go to zero so now what i do is
i use this entire expression
to write this v plus v of t plus h and
the reason i want to do that if we kind
of scroll back up is because we see v of
t plus h showing up in the original
definition we care about
so this is just a way of
starting to get a grapple on that a
little bit more a little bit more firmly
so what i'd write
i'd say that that
v of t plus h
v of t plus h that nudged output value
is equal to the original value that i
have
v of t
plus and it's going to be plus this
derivative term and you can kind of
think that it's almost like a taylor
polynomial
where this is our first order term
you know we're evaluating it at whatever
that t is but we're multiplying it by
the value of that nudge that linear term
and then the rest of the stuff is just
some
little o of h
and maybe you'd say shouldn't you be
subtracting off that little o of h and
it's not an actual function it just
represents anything that shrinks and
maybe i should say it's the absolute
value like the magnitude because in this
case
this is a vector-valued quantity you
know that error is a vector so it's the
the size of that vector divided by the
the size of h
goes to zero
so this is the main tool that we're
going to end up using this is
the the way to represent v of t plus h
and now if we go back up to the original
definition
of the vector value derivative and i'll
go ahead and copy that
go ahead and copy that guy
a little bit of
debris
so copied that original definition for
the ordinary derivative of the
composition function and now when i
write things in according to all the
manipulations that we just did
this is really it's still a limit
as h goes to zero
but what we put on the
inside here
is it's f of now instead of writing v of
t plus h i'm going to use everything
that i did up there
it's the value of v at t
plus
the derivative
at our point
times the size of h so again it's kind
of like a taylor polynomial this is your
linear term and then it's plus something
that we don't care about something
that's going to get really small as h
goes small and really small in
comparison to h more importantly and
from that you subtract off
f of v
of t
kind of running off the edge i always
keep running off the edge and all of
that is divided by h
now the point here
is when you look at this limit because
we're taking it as h goes to zero
we'll basically be able to ignore this o
of h component because as h goes to zero
this gets very very small in comparison
to h so everything that's on the inside
here
is basically just the v of t
plus this vector value
right and this is h times some kind of
vector but if you think back i made a
video on the formal definition of the
directional derivative and if you
remember it or if you kind of go back
and take a look now
this is exactly the formal definition of
the directional derivative we're taking
h to go to zero the thing we're
multiplying it by is a certain vector
quantity that vector is the nudge to
your original value
and then we're dividing everything by h
so by definition this entire thing
is the directional derivative in the
direction of
the derivative
of the function of t i'm writing v prime
t instead of getting the whole dv dt
down there
all of that of f evaluated at where well
the place that we're starting is just v
of t
so that's v of
t
and that's it that's the answer because
when you evaluate the directional
derivative the way that you do that you
take the gradient of f
evaluate it at whatever point you're
starting at
in this case it's the output of v of t
and you take the dot product between
that and the vector value derivative
well i mean the dot product between that
and whatever your vector is which in
this case is the vector value derivative
of v
and that's the multivariable chain rule
and if you look if you look back through
the line of reasoning it all really did
match the thoughts of kind of nudging
nudging and seeing how that nudged right
because the reason we thought to use the
vector value derivative was because of
that intuition and the reason for all
the manipulation that i did is just
because i wanted to be able to express
what the res what a nudge to the input
of v looks like and what that looks like
is the original value plus a certain a
certain vector here this was the
resulting nudge in the intermediary
space i wanted to express that in a
formal way and sure we have this kind of
o of h term that expresses something
that shrinks really fast
but once you express it like that
you just you just end up plopping out
the original the definition of the
directional derivative
so i hope that gives kind of a
satisfying reason for those of you who
are a little bit more rigor-inclined for
why the multi-variable chain rule works
i should also maybe mention there's a a
more general multi-variable chain rule
for vector-valued functions i'll get to
that at another point when i talk about
the connections between multi-variable
calculus and linear algebra but for now
that's that's pretty much all you need
to know on the multi-variable chain rule
when the ultimate composition is you
know just a real number to a real number
and i'll see you next video